The routes are pulling on,
you can measure rat motivation by how
hard they pull on this on the spring,
let's say,
and they're more motivated if they're
running away and running towards.
But let's go back to play.
So you can take juvenile routes who
haven't been able to play for a while,
maybe they've been isolated or maybe
they just haven't been able to engage in
physical activity like many school
children that you might be thinking
about,
um,
neither allowed to play nor allowed to
engage in physical activity.
And there's a reason I'm telling you
that.
So anyways,
you get one of these little rats and you
can measure all hardy wants,
how hard it,
he'll pull the go out and play or how
many buttons he'll push,
you know,
and that gives you an indication of his
motivation.
So anyways,
you can see that the play deprived
juvenile rat will fight harder to play
than a non play deprived.
You've now rat.
And so you can infer that the rat wants
to go play.
And uh,
you know,
you do that,
you do the same measurement with
everyone around you.
If they want to do something,
you're going to poke and prod out them
to see what sort of things they're
willing to overcome in order to go and
do that.
You'll object even if you don't really
object.
It's like it's a measurement device.
And if they're willing to overcome a
bunch of your objections,
then you think,
oh,
well maybe they really want to.
And that's another thing to really know
if there's something you want,
you need about five arguments about why
you wanted,
because the probability that the person
who's opposing you will have five
arguments about why you shouldn't have
it,
is very low.
They just won't have thought it through
enough.
So the other thing that happens in the
future authoring exercises that you're
asked to articulate the reasons for all
the goals that come out of your vision
of the future.
So you're asked like why would it be
good for you?
Why would it be good for your family?
Why would it be good for broader
society?
And so that gives you a three levels of
argumentation right there,
and if you have it articulated down into
detail and it's related to other
important goals,
then you're.
You're a hell of a thing to argue with
because people just aren't that deep by
which I mean they just don't have that
many levels of explanation or objection.
And it's also really useful in
relationship to your own mind.
Because if you want to do something
that's difficult and that requires
energy,
a lot of different subsystems in your
mind,
you're going to throw up objections.
It's like,
well,
maybe that isn't what you should be
doing right now.
Maybe you should be doing the dishes or
vacuuming or watching TV or looking at
youtube,
or if you're really sneaky when you're
trying to do something hard,
what your brain does is give you
something else hard to do that's not
quite as hard so that you can feel
justified in not doing the thing you're
supposed to because you're doing
something else useful.
And if you give into that temptation,
which you often will,
then it winds and because it winds,
it gets a little dopamine kick and it
grows stronger.
Every.
Anything you let when the internal
argument grows and anything you let be
defeated,
shrinks because it's punished.
It doesn't get to have its way.
So that's another thing really to
remember is don't practice what you do
not want to become.
And because those are their neurological
circuits,
you build those things in there,
man,
they're,
they're not going anywhere.
You can build another machine to inhibit
them.
That's the best you can do.
Once they're in there,
you can't get them out.
So.
And then the ones you build to inhibit
can be taken out by stress.
And the old habits will come back up.
So you gotta be careful what you say and
what you do because you,
you build yourself that way.